around the time of e3 this year it
became apparent that while 2014 was
certainly going to be packed to the brim
with really cool games they weren't
actually going to be released until 2015
a number of larger-than-life triple-a
releases were apparently just to me need
to get out this year and while that
means we have a lot to look forward to
in 2015 there's still a few months of
seriously promising gaming experiences
to come this year first up is against
out next week and is my personal most
anticipated title of 2014 if the third
game in the longest journey universe
dreamfall chapters dreamfall chapters
blitzed its way through a successful
Kickstarter a while back and now we're
finally getting the first episode of the
adventure game sequel the saga has a
huge cult following thanks to the
critically acclaimed original The
Longest Journey which came out in 1999
if you're a fan of strong character
development fantasy worlds with epic
narratives and a heavy dose of wealth
saving this could be your cup of tea not
a lot of games can earn a perfect 10 on
GameSpot the last of which was Super
Mario Galaxy 2 in 2010 but now another
is landed and it's none other than
Bayonetta Terfel where you pay another
two also happens to be landing this week
in the West so of your desperation for a
great 2014 release can't wait any longer
this is a great game for you to say a
site's on this over-the-top action game
has executed all of the right moves to
prove to naysayers that it's not just a
game being bought for its sexy
protagonist the combat is smart and
satisfyingly it demands skill and
mastery of its fighting system whether
or not you've got yourself a Wii U it
seems like this might be a really good
item for the reason to buy column if you
don't have a Wii U and you're not that
keen on adventure games this year isn't
done delivering to you either let's
continue with sunset overdrive for Xbox
one this one will have had a hard time
falling under your radar thanks to the
frantic energy and bright colorful world
that developer insomniac
has been so keen to show up you'll be
able to get your action on here servo
mostly with guns wall running in Braille
grinding the plot is a mishmash of
nonsensical madness but this one is
touted to be worth it for the momentum
focused gameplay under the 8 player coop
should you be able to find a friend also
keen to fight humans who've overdosed on
an energy drink to take it in a totally
different direction sid meier's
civilization beyond Earth it's coming
so it's Civ in space again basically
you'll be found in colonies on alien
planets and helping rebuild mankind
who's recovering from a mysterious
catastrophic event known as the great
mistake beyond Earth is a spiritual
successor to the critically acclaimed
Alpha century which came out in 1999 the
sci-fi focus of beyond Earth should be
attractive thanks to a balance between
the typical foundations of a sieve game
with city-based
progression leaves a tile based map
turn-based gameplay and so on alongside
human factions that are now divided by
different philosophies on human
advancement that then shapes players
technological advancement and unlocks
unique units finally November 18 of this
year is going to be a really really good
day because if you're into high fantasy
RPGs or dense Action shooters you're
going to be really happy Dragon Age
Inquisition may have been pushed back a
hell of a lot already after its initial
year-long delay but developer Bioware
seemed pretty sure that the 18th of
November will be the date to jot in your
diary although I'd use a pencil just in
case Dragon Age Origins was a smash hit
and although Dragon Age 2 caused some
divisive opinions for not being quite as
good as the original we have pretty high
hopes for the third installment it's
only been a three-year wait but high
fantasy RPGs of this budget magnitude
don't come along every day
and assuming Bioware Q to the enormous
open-world and character customization
options they're promising Inquisition
should be worth the wait though really
really long wait
finally if controversial box art warring
elephants and a potentially premature
DLC pack
are all you know about far cry 4 it
could be worth your while to dig a
little deeper in typical Far Cry style
the dark and twisted story focuses on
characters both evil and well-meaning in
the middle of a civil war the mildly
sadistic and narcissistic pagan min has
appointed himself king of the
mountainous Himalayas and for the first
time in the history of the series the
main characters are natives to the
country that the game takes place in as
with the earlier installments far cry 4
has a large open world map to explore
has a bevy of combat options intended to
spice up your play and there are
multiple endings to work toward as you
make your way through the story what is
your most anticipated 2014 release is it
one of the ones I mentioned or a whole
other game i didn't include let me know
down in the comments and I'll catch you
next week